on quitte le judo on passe au handball
avec l'équipe de montigny le bretonneux
l'équipe féminine qui se débrouille
plutôt bien en ce début de saison et la
capitaine n'est pas étrangère à ces bons
résultats
oui tout à fait on suit l'équipe de
presque toutes les semaines ils font un
bon début de saison malgré un effectif
réduit et match après match et une
joueuse qui explose et qui multiplie les
performances de choix et de qualité
c'est gabriel par le maire la capitaine
et arrière gauche nous avons décidé de
faire un portrait réalisé avec patrick
jacques de dixmude cette saison à
montigny gabriel par l'horaire porte le
maillot machine à buts dernière batterie
de lucarnes face à plouvorn
l'arrière gauche a marqué le tiers des
buts de son équipe avec 10 réalisations
une victoire qui fait du bien après
trois défaites consécutives d'après sur
un poste d'arrière donc c'est vrai que
sur l'attaqué placée sur le jeu qu'on
met en place en attaque placée
on a pas mal de combi qui finissent sur
les arrières donc ça me donne plus de
chance sur attaque classique une ailière
lui est une chose importante du
dispositif de l'équipe c'est une buteuse
à lens une deuxième fille qui doutent
pas du tout après après un début de
saison elle marquait beaucoup de buts
mais elle avait son petit péché mignon
de perdre beaucoup de ballons et lala
samedi à la famille et l'efficacité et
défensivement et offensivement ce qu'a
fait quand même 10 sur 11 aux tirs
ce qui est quand même pas rien issu
d'une famille de handballeur à 14 ans
gabriel et poussé sur les parcs et par
sa mère formé au pôle espoirs de
strasbourg pendant trois saisons
gaby fait ses grands débuts en nationale
une aar naïm à l'âge de 17 ans avant de
passer par strasbourg
c'est alors que commence l'histoire
d'amour avec mon team malgré une
séparation de deux ans l'alsacienne
pause durablement ses valises à
coubertin en 2009
cette saison sept responsables
administratifs de 28 ans s'est vu
confier le brassard de capitaine un rôle
qu'elle découvre match après match on
vous aime pas quand les filles sont
fond du trou et qu'elle y reste trois
donc j'essaie quand même de faire en
sorte que au moins les filles qui sont à
côté de moi puisque celle à qui je peux
parler sur le terrain avec de l'avant
relève la tête quand quand il le faut ou
continue d'être performante quand quand
elles le sont elle est bien et elle nous
donne toutes les informations
on passe par elle pour quoi que ce soit
et une frappe du capitaine l'arrière et
mentir par rapport à sa stature employés
mais dans l'équipe
le voilà son jeu il me semble logique
soit la capitaine foyer sincèrement pas
qu'ils mettent d'autres comme capitaine
cette année elle est respectée par le
groupe après pour pouvoir te brassard il
faut quelqu'un qui soit bien respectée
par le groupe et qui lui paraît qui est
une voix qui porte
c'est un peu ce qu'elle a pas pour
l'instant parce qu'elle a un peu de mal
à s'imposer
atout offensif numéro un de la smb
handball avec 36 buts en cinq journées
soit plus de sept buts par match en
moyenne
gabriel par l'horaire montre le chemin
ses coéquipières pour atteindre
l'objectif de fin de saison le maintien
en nationale 2 1 1 tient d'ailleurs qui
est en bonne voie puisque ce week-end
les joueuses de stéphane paysans se sont
imposés avait à la face à lège cap
ferret 24 buts à vingt et une petite
performance de gabriel perwer 5 buts bon
va pas lui en tenir rigueur
c'est que ça reste une très bonne
moyenne on va passer au rugby rwc
wilfried ce week-end le sky rugby joué
contre athis mons lors de la lui 4e
journée de championnat d'honneur
l'occasion de s'associer à une belle
cause celle de lass de l'association
laurette fugain qui lutte contre la
leucémie et le manque de dons d'organes
un sujet d'alice gastines et d'élodie
moines
comme chaque année le rugby club de
saint quentin en yvelines s'associer une
action de solidarité
cette fois ci c'est à l'association
laurette fugain qui rompt les dons et
recettes de la buvette lors d'un match
de championnat contre athis-mons commune
de l'essonne pour unir le club dispense
le club ami nautisme ans aujourd'hui
notre adversaire mais m le rugby c'est
de l'amitié d'abord
donc avaient organisé lanta c'est donc
une action caritative autour des restos
du coeur nous amuser vient participer et
nous avions appris cette occasion que le
club nautique et l'un des joueurs de
culture ne dispense a perdu son temps
piqûre d'une audio sony l'association a
en effet pour objectif de sensibiliser
au don de plaquettes et de moelle dans
la lutte contre la leucémie
elle a été créée en 2002 par stéphanie
fugain la maire de lorette décédé à 22
ans d'une leucémie
c'est aussi par le biais du créateur du
site internet du club sportif et de
l'association que le lien c'est fait ce
dernier a réalisé gratuitement le
nouveau site de l'association et
soutient ces actions le combat porte
principalement sur le fait d'informer le
public sur le don le don de plaquettes
le don de moelle osseuse et le don de
sang mais surtout les deux premiers
pourquoi parce qu'elle est malade
atteint de leucémie ont un grand besoin
de ces dons là et que si on leur donne
pas tout simplement il meurt prochain à
un moment fort pour l'association
laurette fugain les concerts return to
rock les 19 et 20 novembre à la cigale à
paris dont les recettes lui seront
intégralement reversés et pour la petite
histoire le sky rugby a remporté ce
match sur le score de 20 à 10 on reste
dans le rugby mais on part à plaisir
cette fois-ci autre championnat autre
championnat fédérale 3 le prc le plus et
plaisir rugby club s'est imposé ce
week-end 21 à 11 face à nogent le rotrou
au stade robert barran les spectateurs
ont eu droit en première mi-temps à un
match des buteurs
à ce petit jeu c'est le plaisir wa cyril
barthet qui a été le plus régulier avant
qu'en seconde mi-temps le prc et mc
marque trois essais avec cette victoire
les jaunes et bleus confortent leur
quatrième place au championnat
après le rugby on passe au football il y
avait des matches également ce week end
et même si le 11 novembre était le
dimanche
oui c'était dimanche du coup ben ahui en
cours a joué samedi soir et les
guyancourt toi jouer face à evry mené
rapidement 1-0 ils reviennent au score à
l'heure de jeu mais la défense
saint-quentinoise a connu quelques
cafouillages notamment sur corner il ya
eu des problèmes de dégagement score
final 3 buts à 2 les saint quentinois
rétrograde à la 5e place de leur
championnat de promotion d'honneur
c'est la deuxième conte de défaites
consécutives pour pour le fbi en cours
va falloir vite réagir sinon la zone
rouge pourrait
pointer son nez toujours en ph en foot
ball trap s'est imposé 2 buts à 0 sur la
pelouse d'epinay remonte à la sixième
place de son championnat
enfin en division d'honneur versailles a
pris sa revanche de coupe de france face
aux lilas il s'était incliné au aux
penaltys avec après une longue longue
séance de penalty cette fois ci ils
s'imposent 1 but à 0 le fcv est
désormais deuxième de dh deux autres
résultats le premier concerne le tennis
tout d'abord oui le tennis on avait on
parlait la semaine dernière du
tennis-club de plaisir qui s'était hissé
en nationale une à la deuxième division
française
c'est très très compliqué ce début de
saison puisque ce week-end les équipes
hommes et femmes ont perdu les hommes 5
à 1 à toulouse et 6 0 pour les femmes à
nice les petits rois se confondent donc
avec beaucoup de difficultés au niveau
et risque de faire l'ascenseur en
nationale 1b deuxième résultat second
résultat ce sera le dernier ce soir
c'est du tir subaquatique le trophée
saint fons trophy 500 swiss et le tir
subaquatique
c'est le trophée organisé par la palme
plaisir oise le club de plongée de
plaisir qui accueillait donc une manche
de coupe de france et les tireurs
plaisir war ont conservé leur titre par
équipe en individuel 6,20 bentobal le
responsable de la section plongée de la
palme que nous avions reçu la semaine
dernière a été a fini deuxième de
l'épreuve ou au général deux records de
france ont été battus ce week-end au
niveau général chez les hommes et lors
du combiné chez les femmes
merci anthony pour cette page sports on
vous retrouve lundi prochain au même
horaire en direct entre 18 et 19 heures
si vous nous suivez quotidiennement
c'est la fin de cette édition du 7 8 si
vous souhaitez revoir tous nos
reportages rendez vous sur notre site
internet
et si vous voulez également en savoir
plus sur les changements qui concerne le
réseau de transports de bus ski bus
puisque de nouveaux horaires de
nouvelles lignes sont en service depuis
aujourd'hui depuis la rentrée des
vacances vous aurez toutes les
informations sur notre site internet
reportage également prochaine édition du
7 8 demain toujours avec de nouveaux
invités sur ce plateau pour commenter à
l'actualité locale l'actualité de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de versailles
et de sa région bonne soirée